all right hello hello hello this is Nick
Gillespie with reason it is Thursday in
the one o'clock hour uh so it's a reason
live stream I'm joined by my recent
colleague Zach weismiller Zach how you
doing good
all right we got a great show for you to
let's bring in Dave Rubin the one and
only a man who's ideological Odyssey uh
is globetrotting you have gone from
being a Young Turk to being a
independent YouTube phenomenon to being
a self-described classical liberal to
now you are a big uh supporter of Ron
DeSantis you've moved from New York
originally to California now to Florida
Dave Rubin thanks for talking to reason
hey it's good to be with you guys I
would say if I could give a one sentence
uh recap of that political Odyssey it's
that I've gone in the direction of
Freedom that really is it and I think
that will resonate with uh the reason
viewers I hope so uh let's run a clip uh
Dave you and I have talked at various
points over the years here's a uh clip
uh you talking about what matters to you
in politics or in ideology from a 2017
reason interview uh Zach you want to
play that clip
what goes into your definition of a
classical liberal so this has been one
of the biggest issues that I've talked
about for the last couple months first
off a liberal people don't understand
this but a true liberal really is a Live
and Let Live attitude which people
prescribe usually the libertarianism and
I do believe that the state has some use
now I don't want a huge State I firmly
believe in individual liberty more than
anything else and that you have to live
the life you want for yourself that's
the best way for humans to prosper
all right so uh you know that's from
2017 uh which seems like a different
planet right now and I want to commend
you Dave uh like myself I think you look
better now than you did in 2017 so we're
aging pretty gracefully here but Nick
can I tell you something can I tell you
something real 30 seconds on that point
you know at that moment 2017 uh that was
sort of when I was just leaving the left
and I was getting a ton of hate online
and I developed you may know this I
developed alopecia ariata which is a
autoimmune disease where you lose huge
chunks of your hair this this is all my
hair I'm very happy to say but I was
losing quarter sized piece of my hair
about 40 of my hair I was using spray-on
hair all sorts of crazy stuff I was on a
crazy experimental medication which is
why I look very kind of bloated in that
picture and my eyes I look puffy and
whatever uh but I started I changed my
diet a little bit I dealt with stress I
don't use Twitter as much and it all
kind of worked out so well and you you
know since said I mean just I and I I
didn't think you looked bad there to be
quite honest but now that you know now
that you're saying I see the puffiness
um but it is um you know you were in
California you've left California in uh
2021 you moved from California to
Florida uh you know we had the rise
Donald Trump you know the rise and kind
of fall of Donald Trump or rather him
not getting reelected uh we had kovid uh
which you know is you know just like a a
total Black Swan event uh you know that
has changed everything do you still feel
like you are a classical liberal in the
way that you talked about there
um or have you migrated to a different
place on the political Spectrum
no I absolutely believe the same things
that I believed in that interview from
about six years ago and that's what my
whole first book don't burn this book is
about I mean it was a full defense of
Classical liberalism and I laid out as
many of my political beliefs and the
ideology behind it as I as I possibly
could into a you know about a 200 Page
book
um the thing is I don't say classical
liberal that often anymore because
unfortunately the word liberal has been
so mucked up which I sort of implied in
that in that short clip there that's a
continue to run around and say no no I'm
an actual liberal the lefties are nuts
the Democrats are not liberals anymore
if JFK was reincarnated or we could
bring back the annual Patrick Moynihan
or Ed Koch then we'd have some version
of that and then also just because
people are just you know people are busy
and everyone's staring at their phones
all day to have to whittle that slight
difference that you and I Nick have
talked about many times that that you
know razor thin difference I would say
between a classical liberal and a live
libertarian where I would say a
classical liberal sees a little more
utility for the government and and we
could quibble about that
um it's not that I've shifted I think at
this point especially now living in
Florida and seeing what a functional
Slim Trim government can do
um most of my classical liberal ideas
and beliefs they fit within what I would
say is sort of a wide tent or small sea
conservative movement so I think we're
going to probably talk about that a bit
more yeah no I don't think any of my uh
political beliefs from that six years
ago have shifted really okay and you
know talk a little bit you you now are
uh you're part of the blaze Network
Glenn Beck's outfit and things like that
do do those guys that's the blaze uh you
know consider themselves classical
liberals or are they conservatives or
could I guess you know I I hear your
point about the difference between
libertarian and classical liberal
attitude you know it might be uh the
difference in you know the size of a
limited government but do conservatives
are they also classical liberals or is
you know to your right is there
something what's what's the meaningful
difference between being a classical
liberal and being a conservative sure
it's a good question just to clean up
One technical thing so I have I'm fully
like I do my show completely
independently around my boss I do
everything I'm you know I'm with Rumble
which I partly own because I created
locals.com and we merged yeah years ago
I do distribute the show with with the
blaze but they're okay that's a good
distinction to know and also let me say
if if I may just to uh congratulate you
a bit more the uh locals and Rumble
fascinating you know kind of way of
responding to social media or other kind
of New Media platforms becoming really
grabby or sensorial and things like that
um you know what you did with that was
provide a place where people had much
more freedom to do and say and own
whatever they produce so good I
appreciate that and you know hopefully
I'm on this Mortal coil for many more
years but I think when I'm long gone
hopefully the legacy of what we created
with that you know the alternate rails
for for a free and independent uh
internet hopefully that would be a a big
part of my legacy if such a thing exists
as for the distinction between say
conservative and classical liberal
um Glenn Beck for example I think he's
described himself often as a classical
liberal now he has some conservative
beliefs or let's not make this about
Glenn so specifically yeah I think
generally the thing that that takes
someone who truly understands what a
classical liberal is individual rights
laissez-faire economics limited
government the thing that there's the
distinction between that and a
conservative usually has more to do with
traditional religious beliefs where
Liberty you know Libertarians classical
liberals
you know obviously I don't care who you
marry I certainly don't care what you
smoke or what you do in the privacy of
your own home conservatives generally
have attached a little more of their
traditional religious beliefs to the
political realm now that's obviously not
the spot that I'm in I'm I'm married to
a man and I have two children that's
that's certainly not what's thought of
as traditionally conservative but what I
can tell you is this I have found almost
without exception minor exceptions
conservatives to be way more not just
open-minded but tolerant and welcoming
of people of different beliefs and
willing to agree to disagree the best
example I can give you that give you of
that is that a couple years ago I spoke
at Liberty University it's the largest
Evangelical College you know Jerry
Falwell country uh in the United States
and it used to be Jerry Falwell Jr
he got into a little bit of trouble
there yeah nobody's perfect okay uh but
at the uh I spoke there for their Sunday
convocation and this is an event they do
every Sunday it's a part religious part
political part educational event 14
000 students I mean it was absolutely
massive I'm guessing it was mandatory
but that still is an immense audience
yes yeah I I actually I honestly I don't
know uh if it's mandatory but either way
it was put back to the gills these kids
know Meyer these young people they know
my political beliefs they know my story
blah blah blah I gave my speech they
didn't ask me to say or not say anything
Standing Ovation I spent the day
wandering around the campus getting high
fives and taking selfies from the kids
and it was fairly obvious that some of
them had some certainly some religious
disagreements with me but that we
roughly want to live in the same country
and that to me is the place that's
interesting how do we take guys like you
and how do we take those libertarian
beliefs and connected in a society with
people that that have say more
Traditional Values or are more concerned
you know I think you're probably more
libertarian on say all drugs than I am
for example right but we clearly want to
live in the same country and that's the
place where we can do some work and
unfortunately on the left it's pretty
much just scorched Earth at this point
can I ask one uh quiet follow-up
question on this before we move on to
the discussion of DeSantis in that
opening click Cliff uh clip Dave you
talk about the importance of individual
rights or you know the it's it's all
about protecting the individual sphere
of choice and that is is that something
that's still at the center of what you
believe and do you think that's at the
center of where conservatism is right
now because you do hear a lot of talk of
things like you know common good
conservatism and a little bit more of a
collectivist approach to things do you
Embrace that or are you still you know
liberal at your core yeah well certainly
from my own personal belief I absolutely
believe that individual rights that
everyone who is in a society a country
that has borders for a reason each
nation state we should treat each
individual person with the exact same
rights there's no such thing as gay
rights or black rights or trans rights
or anything else if you are human and
you are here legally you should be
treated equally under the law period as
for the the next part of what you're
talking about I think that's sort of
like what Society building is all about
that you know once you start with the
individual you have then you know you
build up it's a bottom-up thing that of
course Libertarians are very comfortable
with you have say your individual life
you have your family life you have your
town life that expands into your City
Life your state life the federal
government life this is where we're
going to have some push and pull
probably and where I'll have some push
and pull with the conservative movement
especially if DeSantis uh really
continues and I and I think this is
going to continue quite well actually
um because yeah there you can start
wandering into some territory that maybe
a guy like me wouldn't be that
comfortable with and certainly I don't
think you guys would be that comfortable
with
um but again this is where that that
agree to disagree or that that 250 years
of America that was pretty much working
uh that's what we have to get back to
okay well let's talk about DeSantis you
know uh you you have come out in favor
of DeSantis you had a uh a video op-ed
or you know on your YouTube channel it
said something like you know three
reasons I'm in favor of Ron DeSantis
things like that what is the case you
know succinctly because we're going to
talk about this for an hour uh but let's
lay out the thesis statement Ron
DeSantis for Libertarians like why
should Libertarians who are going to
have some you know kind of reservations
about some of the stuff he does uh you
know and not simply eating pudding with
his fingers
um what's the case for Rhonda Santos to
libertarian rates well first off I mean
the guy was part of the freedom caucus
when he was in congress with a bunch of
other guys that Libertarians seemed to
like uh he is the most I would say
limited government but uses government
when it should be used uh politician
that we have probably in America
certainly now at a national level uh you
know Florida I mean we can do a couple
like just basic libertarian things here
Florida is a no income tax state that is
great for Libertarians uh Florida we
have we have the rule of law now I think
we probably have some little
disagreements maybe on levels of
policing or that sort of thing but
Libertarians want to protect life and
want to protect property that's being
done incredibly well uh here in Florida
actually Zach you you mentioned right
before we started you live in one of the
few places that's Democrat run now in
Florida Florida which is almost all red
now don't forget DeSantis won his first
election in 2018 by 30 000 votes to a
guy who turned out to be a meth addict
he won his re-elect by 1.6 million votes
it's basically the biggest landslide in
Florida history he turned what was at
one time a blue State then a purple
State into basically the most red state
in the country and from what I've seen
he's really only using government when
it's effective and uh because I know
Libertarians don't like red tape and
don't like regulation we had that
unbelievably horrific it's less than a
year ago basically Category 5 hurricane
Ian hit Southwest Florida the rebuild
there has been so unbelievably fast
because he went in cut all the red tape
and they have rebuilt I mean I've been
there it's on the other coast I'm here
in Miami but that Sanibel Bridge it's a
three mile bridge it would have taken
any other state two years to rebuild
that thing they've had it functional in
about three weeks that's just one little
example of the type of things that he's
done he doesn't believe in government
and then we could do all the covid stuff
I mean he opened up the state he made
sure the kids were going back to schools
he was fighting against masks he you
know he's also try to get ESG out of all
of our government institutions I mean we
could we could go on and on throughout
that's a that's a good starting point uh
Zach you want to play the uh clip from
uh
you know he announcement via Twitter
yeah yes yeah he took to Twitter spaces
last week with David sex and Elon Musk
co-hosting him to make his presidential
announcement which was something
different that no other candidate has
done before so perhaps we can talk a
little bit about that choice and and why
he did that but I just want us to listen
to the opening pitch that DeSantis made
to voters and get your reaction Dave to
substance of that pitch
oh I am running for president of the
United States to lead our Great American
comeback look we know our country's
going in the wrong direction we see it
with our eyes and we feel it in our
bones our Southern borders collapse
drugs are pouring into the country our
cities are being hollowed out by spiking
crime the federal government's making it
harder for the average family to make
ends meet and to attain and maintain a
middle-class lifestyle and our president
well he lacks Vigor flounders in the
face of our nation's challenges and he
takes his cues from the woke mob I don't
think it has to be this way American
decline is not inevitable it is a choice
and we should choose a new Direction a
path that will lead to American
revitalization
what was your reaction to his opening
pitch well can I tell you the line that
really struck me there was I don't think
it has to be this way he's right it
doesn't have to be this way this
Insanity that we are dealing with at the
border with endless inflation with
politicians that refuse to say anything
remotely true with debt ceilings that
constantly rise and all of these endless
things it doesn't have to be this way
but I think the collective memory we
don't like collectivism but the
collective memory of Americans right now
is sort of like oh it's been bad for a
while and you know we're kind of at the
end the Empire's over let's just manage
the destruction and hopefully the
zombies don't eat our faces on I don't
think it has to be that way and I think
DeSantis has actually proven that here
in Florida which is why I always tell
people you know we can talk about policy
all day long and policing and economics
and all of that stuff we can do it all
day long but for the people that are not
particularly political that are just
going to vote at the end of the day
because it's election day and okay I'm
not really sure what I'm going to do all
you have to do is look at where people
are going and where they are fleeing
from and a million plus people have come
to Florida in three years 1200 people a
day even now and California has lost
about 1.3 million people New York has
lost over a million people and it's
obviously not just Florida it's Texas
Tennessee Wyoming a couple other states
uh Iowa is doing quite well but that to
me at the end is the is the key point
where do people want to live at post
covet post all of this dystopian uh
really Draconian horrible stuff in terms
of Rights and our ability to live as we
see fit some places defended American
principles some did not so I I thought I
also thought going to Twitter was a good
idea I happen to be at Twitter that day
which was a complete coincidence meeting
Elon later that night but going to
Twitter as opposed to you know one of
the things that I'm frustrated with
Trump on is he's right when it comes to
fake news CNN he's right when it comes
to the failing New York Times but then
he does town halls with CNN to put them
on life support he does interviews
exclusives with Maggie Haberman at the
New York Times DeSantis guess what time
it is so he's like no I'm gonna run
around them and guess what they all
covered it now did they cover it fairly
probably not that's a separate issue but
I think I think his age you know he's
younger uh Zach I don't know how old you
are but he's certainly younger than Nick
and I he's 44. uh like we need a
generational shift here too so I I think
he has everything
he look I don't worship politicians I'm
just like you guys I would rather a
state where I barely knew the
politicians or knew who they were
however this once in a while a guy comes
along who isn't a megalomaniac who has a
good pedigree who's doing the right
things who is adjusted as information
changed as he did with kovid and I think
that it's incumbent on us for those of
us that speak about politics or issues
for a living uh to fight for the people
that are doing that can I ask uh you
know one of the things you're you know
you're hitting a lot of high notes for
uh DeSantis uh which makes sense I'm
thinking uh you know things are roughly
analogous to uh the late 70s
um you know and I'm older than you Dave
so I I remember that more than you might
but you know people were exhausted
people retired the economy was going
sideways and and slightly down uh it
looked like militarily the U.S was
floundering
um you know people it was just a bad a
you know kind of slushy moment Reagan
came along and one of the things that
Reagan really exuded was optimism and
confidence I mean he said a lot of
limited government Stuff Etc but
somebody like DeSantis and this is you
know a Vibe check really I don't see him
as being optimistic uh in the way that
Reagan Reagan was funny Reagan reached
out to people who disagreed with him do
you think DeSantis does he you know he
see he's a very old 44 year old
um he does not you know whereas Reagan
was a very young you know 70 year old or
something like that but
um you know do you feel that DeSantis
exudes optimism on a personal level um
he seems very combative and very
defensive when he's talking sure well
first let me address the Reagan thing
you know Reagan really was an
unbelievably special character you have
to remember this guy was an actor in
Hollywood before eventually you know in
a democratic of his life and then
eventually becomes repub looking
governor and then probably you know by
most certainly conservative standards
the best Republican president we've had
in let's say 100 years something like
that Libertarians might disagree with
that but you know that would be the
conservative point on on Reagan his
ability to to be funny and off the cuff
and tell a joke and go on The Tonight
Show I mean still if you look at my
YouTube search history I watch old
Reagan's speeches and TV appearances
because he was so incredible so I mean
he was so remarkable I I mean I was in
high school when he got shot and he made
a joke as he was going under surgery
after being shot he said like I hope
that doctors are are Republicans
um or something which is incredible do
you know was that was that 1980 if I'm
not mistaken
81. that is actually so I was born in
76. that is one of my first memories as
as a child I remember that watching TV
with my parents and they were freaking
out and I remember seeing a they had
like a sort of cartoon body on the
screen and they were showing where the
bullet went anyway uh so if your
question is is DeSantis Reagan in that
sense of like just like he exudes like
all of that then of course he's not of
course he's not
um I've spent a lot of time with him you
know privately and done public events
with him he likes people a lot he loves
he he's more of a policy wonk I would
say he remembers every freaking vote and
who is on the floor of every you could
literally ask him that vote on that
random thing in 2017 and you were on the
he'll remember absolutely everything I
he loves talking about baseball but is
he Reagan no but as as far as the
positive Vision thing I think he's given
an incredibly positive Vision actually
now now it comes with a uh with a fight
or a bite to it because we are fighting
something so crazy what we now call
wokeness that has done unbelievable
damage to our institutions and our
Republic so he's fighting it with a
certain a certain uh zest or or whatever
whatever you want to call that but I
would also point you to this you know
Donald Trump if you watch interviews
with Donald Trump in the 80s he would go
on Oprah and Phil Donahue and all of
these things you can find them on
YouTube yeah he's very soft-spoken he's
very pleasant his affect is very very
different Oprah's talking about when
he'll run for president and everything
and then I think what happens is when
you're in a system for a certain amount
of time and it lies about you over and
over and everything's working against
you all the time you end up with a much
more Gruff Persona and much more
aggressive Persona like Trump now I
think that's been truncated for DeSantis
a little bit the amount of lies that are
told about this guy that he's racist
because he got rid of a AP
African-American studies course that was
going to be about genderqueer theory
that he somehow pushed something called
don't say gay which didn't the word gay
wasn't even in it it's called hb1557 and
it had to do with parental rights and
education I'm happy to discuss that if
you want
um everything that they have lied to him
about I think he just has an
understanding of that so he treats
things accordingly so I think for most
people you have to decide like do you
want a friend as the president or do you
want an executive who's going to defend
the Constitution and I think it's fairly
obvious to me it may not be obvious to a
lot of people I mean the cult of
personality around the president is
obviously a big thing but I really think
the more people see him and get to know
him I think they're going to like him
more but I'm not completely dismissing
what you're saying what what worries me
about that fight that he has against
wokeness is that I'm not convinced that
he really is going to be a defender of
the Constitution you know like when I
moved to Florida I liked that DeSantis
swerved away from the public health
establishment so a lot of what you're
saying resonates with me Dave I you know
I like that he put a big emphasis on
letting individuals make their own
choices I think it was good for the
people living in Florida I think it was
good for the economy of Florida what I
don't like about the
post-covid desantises now he seems
pretty willing to use state power to
advance a conservative social agenda and
punish his enemies and I'm worried so
what would what would be an example of
that I I assume you mean Disney right
that's one uh that that's a great
example yes okay so we should we should
do the Disney thing look Disney had
tons I've actually got a list of them
here because I had a feeling you were
going to ask me about them so I can read
them all off to you Disney because I
know this is an issue with Libertarians
that we should never use the government
for anything except what he did was use
the government in the exact way that
Libertarians want the government to be
used you don't want government overreach
but you do want to make sure there isn't
crony capitalism Disney took DeSantis
took special benefits away from Disney
meaning Disney had been granted special
benefits related to building codes and
water rights and this airport and taxes
and a whole bunch more I'm happy to read
them all off to you that were not
granted to their competitors such as Sea
World and Universal Studios and Gator
World which in essence do the same thing
they're they're theme parks so Disney he
then took their special rights away thus
evening the playing field which is to me
the ultimate thing that a Libertarian
would want you would want the government
only to act to even the playing field so
the the playing field was like this and
then he use the government to do this
there are thousands right or hundreds of
special tax districts in Florida that
were in place and remain in place he
also carved out in his social media law
he carved out an exception for Disney
before they crossed him on gay rights
um so it seems like it's La I mean part
of I you know and I'll let Zach speak
for himself but for me part of it is
that he is not acting out of principle
he's actually acting out of personal
Peak and that seems to be coming through
in others I don't think so you know I
see I I understand the position I
suppose uh well I don't understand the
position in that he wasn't doing
anything against gay rights so let's
just put that aside I mean he's done
nothing again
let me put it this way that it's you
know uh the uh don't say gay law or the
parental rights and you know I think
it's this is something that
um I think Libertarians need to uh kind
of grapple with more fully which is that
Ron DeSantis signed what is you know
either the leading or certainly one of
the best school choice bills uh in the
state in the country yeah uh but then he
does this and he did this with masks he
did this with other things where he's
saying in order to preclude certain
choices I'm going to say at the state
level local school districts local
businesses can't make certain types of
choices and for me that's worrying
because what I see as somebody as he
gains more power is going to start to
exert his personal choices or a
conservative ideological agenda on more
and more aspects of everyday life right
can you just give me an example of what
you're talking about because I don't
know yeah yeah so what I'm saying is is
that if you want school choice and if
you believe in parental rights you
should give money to parents and they
can send their school their kids to
whatever whatever schools they want
public or private but then if you start
to say okay and and also by the way
schools cannot teach this schools cannot
do this schools cannot XYZ that's
confusing to me
um and it strikes me as maybe that's the
difference between being conservative
and being a Libertarian but I find it
worrying well well first off as long as
the government has anything to do with
education then somebody has to know
they're going to fund it no actually
they don't really but no no I get the
libertarian position on this I I could
get there I'm all for school choice and
if you want to do you know what's
happening right now and it's largely in
part because of Florida's blueprint but
it's happening in Iowa and Arkansas and
uh Montana and several other states is
funding of students as opposed to
systems I think we're probably in
agreement that that's the best way to do
it if you think that there should be any
funding tax related whatsoever I I don't
have a problem yeah I don't have a
problem I I am a uh a squishy
libertarian okay so so in that regard so
if we're roughly agreed on that well
then the question is okay so if you're
saying you're going going to have some
level of public education somebody has
to decide what's in that curriculum now
the fact is and I would think that Local
Schools would do that local school
districts Local Schools sure parents and
I mean why why is the state getting
involved in saying you can't have this
kind of curriculum you can't have that
kind of curriculum well first off that's
not that's actually not what's happening
I mean when people talk about these book
Bannings all they've done is kicked it
back to the districts to say are you
okay with certain books in your school
the really the only book that has been
banned and please people check me on
this there have been books that have
been moved from say you know third grade
reading level to Middle School reading
level so I literally just ourselves
go ahead no the only book that's been
banned has been this what's the book
it's called the gay uh gender queer
which literally teaches you how to have
gay sex now I don't care if it's gay sex
or straight sex but why is that in a
library we all know that's wrong we all
know that's wrong but on the on the
specific part about the parental rights
in education I mean try I say this when
I'm doing public talks all the time
everyone watching this right now
including you guys try to remember what
it was like to be in third grade now try
to remember your think about your third
grade teacher for just a moment get her
name in your head and picture her now
try to imagine if she had been talking
to you about gender identity and sex
privately privately for months possibly
calling you a name of the opposite sex
and your parents didn't know about it
absolutely so absolutely insane yeah
back in the day that's part of that law
no absolutely to go to the zoo back in
the day you'd have to have parents sign
a letter to make sure you weren't eaten
by the line and then that is all well
and good uh and it's also I I think if
you actually give parents the right and
the ability to choose their schools you
know this stuff takes care of itself but
then to say okay any uh any discussion
of sexual orientation uh or of gender
identity in grades K through 12 or K
through a or at higher ed to try and
squeeze out whatever it passes for
critical race Theory these are troubling
to me that's and I'm saying this from a
Libertarian perspective I don't expect
conservatives to agree and I don't
necessarily expect uh liberals or
progressives to agree but this is what
is I think this is the nut that if
DeSantis wants the libertarian vote this
is what he has to figure out yeah and
it's also just to return to the Disney
example for a second because you know
what what happened there is that Disney
had there's a basically privatized
version of government running this area
around Disney and then Disney came the
Disney CEO came out against this
education law you can agree or disagree
but that's his rights as a private
citizen and then they decided to take a
special look at this and I interviewed
the lawmaker behind this and he told me
that you know there's all this pressure
for companies to go woke so they're
going to learn that in Florida there's
consequences for that so they're out
there making statements like this
DeSantis every day has been making
statements that Disney is just jotting
down for their court case to show that
it's retribution like anyone who's
looking at the situation can see its
retribution and it's not just for Disney
there's other companies there's uh
Airbnb he went after them because he
didn't like that they pulled out of
operation their operations out of the
West Bank uh in Israel uh there's uh the
stop woke act where they
um prescribed they said that companies
could not engage in certain types of
diversity trainings and you know we can
have that debate about the public sphere
and what's appropriate in public schools
but my problem is that DeSantis often
just erases that or just glosses over
that public private distinction and I
find it disturbing for somebody who's
been considered uh to move up to the
presidential level yeah I I truly mean
this respectfully guys I hope it will
come across that way but this is why
Libertarians don't make inroads
politically because I'm not saying that
you're completely wrong on at the ideal
level philosophically what you're saying
DeSantis fighting against diversity in
our schools you know diversity equity
and inclusion it's the most
anti-American actually
anti-constitutional idea that you would
be hiring certainly that the government
would be doing it hiring based on
sexuality and skin color and everything
else so if the it because then otherwise
it sends it seems to me that maybe and
maybe this is true Zach perhaps you're
more of an anarchist that they're real
that the government should sort of never
do anything you know because because
otherwise if the government never does
anything look again I said this earlier
but look again what Oak has accomplished
just in the last five years it has
demolished basically everything we have
the Democrat Party is basically run by
racists at this point and people who
want reparations and all of this
craziness finally someone has come in
and said I'm going to do my best to
clean this stuff up now we can we can
Whittle and we can do it for the next
hour if you want riddle every little
decision down but on one hand it's
complicated though is that the question
really is should someone be allowed to
run a private woke school or a private
company that is quote unquote woke
should that be allowed or should the
government do something about well no of
course you can run a pro you can run a
private whoa company of course you can
but you don't necessarily get special
benefits from the government again
Disney had special benefits at the end
of this they are going to be treated
like everybody else which I'm pretty
sure is a very libertarian principle you
would want all corporations to be
treated exactly the same way
let's talk about covet Zach do you want
to play the clip uh because this is
something where I think there's
substantial agreement that uh desantis's
response to covet which he did uh you
know over a lot of press uh kind of
outpouring of anger and fear uh do you
want to play the clip from his Twitter
space
when in Florida we proved it could be
done we chose facts over fear education
over indoctrination Law and Order over
rioting and disorder we held the line
when Freedom hung into balance and we're
thriving as a result Florida is the
nation's fastest growing State we're
number one in net in migration number
one in new business formations recently
ranked number one in education we have a
50-year low crime rate and one of the
lowest tax in debt per capita in America
but we also understand governing is not
entertainment it's not about building a
brand or virtue signaling it is about
delivering results
Let's uh you guys both uh live on uh you
guys both lived in California under
Gavin Newsom California had the first
kind of wide scale uh shelter at you
know in home uh shelter in place uh kind
of restrictions and whatnot and you
moved to Florida Dave what was the what
was the difference uh you know living in
California versus living in Florida
during covet
yeah well first off you know that I uh
there's a beautiful sort of uh comeback
to my story because the thing that woke
me up originally is who a lot of the
leftism very famously was that interview
that I did about eight years ago with
Larry Elder where he you know sort of
beat me senseless about systemic racism
Larry I'm sure everybody knows who Larry
is he's mostly a Libertarian actually I
think now he calls himself a
conservative but black black libertarian
conservative type thinker anyway he
ended up running uh against Gavin Newsom
as everyone knows in that recall and I
was campaigning with him so the guy who
sort of woke me up politically seven
eight years later I'm running with him
opening for him at events to get rid of
Gavin Newsom the recall election which
obviously didn't turn out well I believe
it was on uh September 12th if I'm not
mistaken of 2021 three days later I was
audited by the state of California after
running against Gavin Newsom very
publicly uh and I put my house for sale
that day and I was gone uh you know
basically two and a half months later in
December everyone gets how Draconian and
horrible lockdowns were and the
inconsistencies and the fake vax
passports that people were using I am
not vaccinated I am very proudly not
vaccinated I think one of the best
moments of my career ever I was on a fox
La TV debating Gloria Allred who is
supposed to be a civil rights lawyer
about vaxes and she dared to say she's
demanding everyone get vacs the civil
rights lawyer and she dared to ask me if
I was vaxxed so I asked her when the
last time she got laid was because I
think those things are equally as uh
relevant you have no right to know what
anyone's done with their personal
medical history
California was absolutely horrible on
top of what It ultimately does to the
human Spirit which is why La is now an
absolute dump and San Francisco is a
zombie apocalypse although that has a
lot to do with drugs and a bunch more of
progressive policies and then on I think
it was December 17th or so 2021 I landed
in Florida and I took a video of it
that's on my Twitter and I'm not kidding
guys I felt something lift off my chest
and the last year and a half of my life
I also have two kids since then has been
the most rewarding year of my life
because I moved two companies here about
a dozen people here everyone is
flourishing everyone's happy there's no
state income tax the fact that I'm
saving money while living here I've told
DeSantis many times he should be
charging an entry tax at this point
um everything's working here and and
people will not crumble when they bring
it all back and and believe me they will
I don't know if you saw the story
yesterday but at uh the I believe it's
the Capitol building in Connecticut on
there's a floor now the third floor you
have to wear masks again I mean the
level of stupidity is endless but there
will be some places that will be
bastions of freedom in Florida I would
say is that the center of that Zach what
was your experience and and certainly
the lockdowns as well as having kids and
dealing with public schools and whatnot
where and and overall costs
um you know we're all factors in your
move what how did you feel about the
covet experience in California versus
Florida I mean I I relate to a lot of
what Dave was saying there I think I
moved out maybe a month or two before he
did it was right on the heels of the
failed Newsome recall election
and it's I felt that similar you know
kind of breathing easy Once I stepped
into the Sunshine State so I have you
know nothing bad to say about Florida
it's a wonderful place to live my
concern is really that
this is the way that this is the beauty
of our Federalist system is that uh Dave
and I were able to vote with our feet so
to speak and get out and my worry about
the DeSantis campaign to some degree is
like their campaigning kind of like on
makeup make America Florida and I think
it's got to be it with the cultural
divisions that we have right now it's
got to be a little bit more like let
Florida be Florida let California be
California let New York be New York and
don't try to bring the you know the
types of laws the types of uh
restrictions on abortion for instance
might be more palatable here in Florida
than they would be on the federal level
and I'm not sure I haven't been
convinced that you know DeSantis is the
kind of federalist or like strict
constitutionalist that I think is really
badly needed for or the country at this
point well that that raises an
interesting question Dave you know it's
different running for governor uh and
and it is amazing you you touched on
this earlier DeSantis squeaked in very
you know with with the minimum amount of
votes almost to become Governors a very
tight race but then blew the doors off
uh you know in reelection I mean he won
with what like 60 or 70 percent of the
vote I mean it was a total blowout but
there's a difference when you're running
for a president and you know this is
part of the question like does DeSantis
doing what he did in Florida does that
make sense on a national level the
reason the reason that I think it does
and Zach I actually understand what
you're saying where to me if you say
make a make America Florida to me that
sounds like the greatest thing ever
right we're going to live freely we're
going to have Safe Streets and we're
going to have fire ants and coral snakes
and alligators
humidity the worst thing that's happened
to me since I was in Florida is about
two weeks ago I heard a loud bang in the
backyard and an iguana huge iguana
probably like you know they're like four
feet when they're this way it fell out
of the tree my dog got it blood flying
all over the place and then I ripped the
Iguana out I threw him in the pool and
he swam around he cleaned himself up
salt water pool and he's okay that's the
most that's the most horrific thing that
has happened to me in Florida look I
understand if you're if you're a
Californian Lefty living in Cal you know
in in Berkeley you're not going to be
thrilled to hear that California might
turn into Florida but what I think
DeSantis really means by that and what I
think most people understand by make
America Florida is how about we just
clean up America a little bit how about
we make sure that we have proper laws so
that our cities don't become all of the
blue cities we can do it Seattle
Portland Chicago New York La San
Francisco et cetera et cetera they're
all Democrat run and they're all
disasters why is it that Florida which I
think has the 13th largest GDP in the
world has very small amount of debt
despite having no income tax why is it
that we are able to take these one
million new refugees from California and
elsewhere and put them into the system
here and our infrastructure hasn't
collapsed yes we do it in southeast
Florida where I am Miami we have a lot
of traffic but you know what he also
escalated I think seven massive
infrastructure projects that were
20-year projects uh to be seven year
projects so we're building like crazy
he's cutting red tape so that we can
what do you do about the things that are
specifically National and stuff because
you know the cities you know cities you
know their their local issues mostly
it's not the federal government but you
you talk if Florida can handle a million
people moving there why can't America
you know a country of 330 million 350
million uh handle a million illegal
immigrants coming every year um you know
what uh DeSantis is very
anti-immigration uh he you know uh you
know and he can talk about it as illegal
or legal but he seems to be against that
Zach mentioned you you know when the uh
the Roe versus Wade was repealed he said
hey I'm going to enforce Florida's
15-week ban but then he very quickly
went along with squeezing it down to six
weeks
um you know should there be a national
ban on abortion because
I mean but these are these this is the
difference between being a governor of a
particular State and then running the
country sure well first off I mean it's
not within the purview of the president
to decide whether there's a National
Abortion ban or not I mean I think that
I happen to be pro-choice I'm guessing
you guys are to some extent yes I was
completely fine with the 15 weeks
actually my personal preference would be
in about 12 weeks but having been in
Florida this is one place that I do have
a personal difference with him having
been in Florida for the last year and a
half and been to basically every
Republican event and conservative event
and plenty of things with DeSantis I
never heard anyone talking about
abortion because it was basically like
you know what we're pretty we're mostly
a pro-life state but we're taking the
same position of 15 mean nobody's really
screaming about it let's Let It Be now
that being said at several events I
heard DeSantis publicly talk about how
his personal belief was different that
he would say from my Catholic faith
dictates that I am pro-life uh he but I
did hear him say several times that he
did he didn't feel that he was going to
move the 15-week thing so I don't know
exactly what happened there that one
might be playing politics a little bit
because if he thought he was running for
president you want to run to the right
of trump so that that might be but I
can't speak for him I'm just telling you
know okay I mean the case that you're
making here with regards to Florida and
kind of transposing that to the the
presidency is that it's competence that
he's run Florida as a competent
executive and that seems to be the way
that he's trying to contrast himself
with someone like Donald Trump he's
trying to say I'm I get it done he kind
of mentions it in that that Twitter
space clip we played earlier you know
we're not about performative politics X
were about results and I'm I'm curious
uh you know as someone who supported
Donald Trump in the past what your
reaction has been to the way Trump has
absorbed the DeSantis announcement we
have a clip here from Donald Trump I'm
going to play in just a second uh that I
think kind of illustrates the the
general tenor and tone that Trump has
taken so far so let's play that and then
get Dave's reaction
Rob the sanctimonious and his poll
numbers are dropping like a rock I would
almost be inclined to say these are
record Falls the question is Rob just
young and experienced a naive or more
troubling is he a fool who has no idea
what the hell he's doing how about the
fact that he had the third most deaths
of any state having to do with the China
virus or coven even Cuomo did better he
was number four and look at Disney and
what a mess it is
could have worked out an easy settlement
but no he wanted to show the fake news
how tough a guy he is
thoughts I mean everything he said there
pardon my French was just a load of
and we all know it and it's like what
I'm sick of with Trump at this point I
don't know why this clip is like even
though I've seen it 20 times it's
particularly bothering me at the moment
I've had a lot of coffee
um is that we he's a magician who we've
seen all the tricks already and he keeps
doing the same tricks and we keep
pretending as if we don't know what's
going oh there is a card up his sleeve I
can't believe it first off can can
either one of you I've been trying to
settle this on the show why is somehow
calling someone rob worse than calling
them Rob let's do that one first does
anyone does that make sense I I think
it's like he's robbing people
okay all right fine so he's robbing
people all right that's one and then now
to sanctimonious I mean if Trump knew
what the word sanctimonious was or
sanctimony was Trump is far more
sanctimonious which is sort of fake
virtue than than Ron DeSantis is uh next
thing he fought this we've already done
the Disney thing so you know my my
feelings on that
um and as far as the poll numbers and
and the name calling and all that you
know General really speaking when you're
30 points As Trump likes to believe he's
30 points ahead he's 40 points ahead
blah blah blah you don't relentlessly
every day have you and every single one
of your surrogates
lying repeatedly DeSantis is a rhino and
a globalist and he Sorrows back then
Paul Ryan back lying about absolutely
everything if you were so confident that
you were in the lead the way that you
purport to be so I think there's a lot
of things going on here but Zach to your
point I did support Trump last time I'm
glad that I did it I took a lot of heat
for doing it it was not easy to do in LA
I believe it was absolutely the right
thing to do I think he was for the most
part an extremely good president but
that doesn't mean he should be king and
God Emperor forever there is a better
choice right now I think I've made my
case fairly well here and and that
should be obvious to most people so I
think the choice for people if you're if
you're gonna vote Republican one way or
another you know you're a Libertarian
you've sort of had it with all these
people but you accept that you know it's
not going to be Gary Johnson again or
something what you have to decide is for
whatever your concerns are let's say on
the school choice thing that you brought
up before Nick let's let's just say even
that you're more right on that than I am
let's just pretend that's that's just
the case empirically you have to decide
okay if DeSantis has done all of these
other things and maybe I'm not
completely with him on this
I should probably vote for him because a
it'll stop the Socialists and the
Communists and God knows what's coming
behind Biden but the other opportunity
and I think this is what I think when
when some Libertarians are frustrated
with me I think this is what it hinges
on it seems obvious to me that for for
people like us who have mostly
libertarian beliefs and you just want
the government out of your life we have
a chance right now to take a guy like
DeSantis and be in the libertarian wing
of that movement and hopefully when it
comes to something like school choice uh
we can hopefully work with him a little
bit there and I think he's been amenable
to that and I think that that's fairly
obvious so that that's a political
calculation uh rather than sort of a
philosophical calculation but I think
that that's what a wide tent would do
we're never I assure you I am never
going to find DeSantis is as close to a
perfect candidate that I'm gonna find
but but you're never going to find the
perfect candidate and and Libertarians
especially will never find the perfect
candidate so what you want to find is
someone who's kind of ballpark there and
then work with them to the best extent
and I think that you will find his
campaign very open to that
that's a very pragmatic way to look at
it and that's partly why we're having
these kinds of conversations because we
want to hash out and and you know I
don't know what I'm gonna do uh yeah I
don't know which way I'm going to vote I
don't know if I'm gonna you know vote
for DeSantis or I'm certainly not going
to vote for Trump
probably not for Biden but you know we
want to be airing our our serious uh
problems with with this candidate and
and I should also just mention uh real
quick that uh you know Trump's Claim
about
um covid deaths in Florida versus New
York we don't want to just let that
slide um you know he's saying New York
had the uh fourth most and Co for the
third well that aligns exactly with
population if if you look at the
population adjust this is the
age-adjusted covid-19 uh death rate
Florida New York California uh and age
adjusted is important because we all
know that the risk uh goes way up the
older you get and uh Florida's
age-adjusted death rate was 245 per 100
000. New York's was 315 or sorry 311
California's 242. so California Florida
about the same New York uh worse so I
mean Trump uh gets no of course he's of
course he's lying about that but you
also have to understand right so when
you age adjust Florida has the second
oldest population but Florida also
fought to remain free so it's not
necessarily about comparing deaths
because life is not just about death
life is about Freedom actually right
life is about your ability to live so he
defended the ability to live and if at
the end of the day with the second
oldest population it caused a few more
deaths and I'm not even saying that it
did that's a that's actually something
that we should all sit with and think
about that do you want your government
to only look at numbers and look at you
as a cog in a system that it can just
move around as it sees fit and decide
when you go outside or not I just want
yeah go uh no thank you that uh
wonderful I just wanted to uh go to a
couple of reader comments and questions
Joseph now says I'm a lifelong Florida
resident who voted for DeSantis despite
typically voting libertarian at a
national level his comments on criminal
justice concern me will ours ever see
the light on that issue uh Chase Oliver
who was a Libertarian party Senate
candidate in Georgia who forced a runoff
between Herschel Walker uh who's you
know one of the dumbest and most
trump-approved candidates in history he
writes if Dave is a classical liberal as
he claims why would he support DeSantis
who has made so many anti-liberal
policies a centerpiece of his brand
assaults on free speech and expression
for instance I think we've covered some
of that but I think I mean what is it
that should say should government
should government be used as a weapon to
attack corporations DeSantis didn't get
rid of the income tax in Florida he
obviously uh came in uh sketch therapy
uh paid two dollars to uh say why is Ron
loving speech laws speech equals
nuisance
uh neocon Ron on loves red red flag and
speech laws uh week on First Amendment
and second amendment uh thank you sketch
therapy for paying a total of four
dollars for those two comments let me uh
ask uh a question and this goes to the
difference between running Florida and
running the country uh DeSantis where do
you think he is on foreign policy Dave
and this is something where Trump I
think actually had a powerful effect and
generally a better effect on the
Republican party than he often is given
credit for because he pulled back from a
kind of Neo neo-conservative imperialist
world uh worldview of the idea of
America as the indispensable nation that
has to be fighting every war everywhere
Etc
um where do you think DeSantis is
falling on that kind of issue well let
me just give credit where credit's due
I'm with you Trump did an absolutely
incredible job on foreign policy I mean
all of the peace deals in the Middle
East which everyone used to be for peace
of the Middle East it was something we
kind of all agree read on these deals
are a hundred percent because of trump
uh and and then of course you know he
got uh Ambassador Friedman and a whole
bunch of other people to make them
happen but these were because of Trump's
foreign policy we did not get into extra
Wars uh we certainly I don't think would
be in the Ukraine war right now we're in
it or not in it we don't declare war
anymore we just fund Wars right I mean
it's all nonsense but but I'm fairly
certain that Trump would not be doing
this I think he would have actually
eventually gotten us out of Afghanistan
in a much more competent way than than
the disaster that happened a couple
August ago I think DeSantis is going to
be pretty freaking close to that again
he was part of the freedom caucus think
about the guys in Congress right now who
are his biggest supporters Thomas Massey
I mean give me a guy you guys like more
than Thomas Massey uh chip Roy give me a
guy you like more than chip Roy like
we'll find out what Senators go his way
but I have a feeling that Ted Cruz and
uh Rand Paul are going to be heading in
his Direction too these are these are
far away what about what is his
relationship with Little Marco uh Marco
Rubio
um I did one event that I brought them
both on stage I I don't know personally
because I pretend that the other one
wasn't there or
I mean you are like you're running all
sorts of funny events and Battle of the
Bands no look I I think my guess is I
this one I actually don't know what the
answer is in terms of what their
relationships like they certainly have a
disagreement on foreign policy right so
Marco Marco's definitely more on sort of
a more old school what you might call a
neocon policy on that I
reason to think that DeSantis is in that
camp you know there was the uh the
statement that he issued on Ukraine to
Tucker which he did slightly uh shift
when he talked to peers people got there
but went really crazy about that but he
said nothing about nation building he's
gone very in on why are we funding these
endless things I think you know this is
also where to me and I and I hope I
would do this with any candidate he's a
governor give the guy a chance to lay it
out I don't think you weren't but I
think this is where you have to give him
a little bit of chance he's done a good
job here we have a I think a very good
sense of what his political philosophy
is and now you have to let that scale
into the other Realms that a governor is
not usually taking care of like foreign
policy I just want to point out that
Magnum Norse uh paid ten dollars on
YouTube thank you Magnum North I uh uh
regret only that that's fiat currency uh
but he writes or she they write is Trump
not the most Libertarian president in
our lifetime he didn't start any wars
and he stopped Wars he also expanded
bombing or you know the aid in Yemen and
whatnot but I you know I let me ask this
of either of you
um you know we hear this a lot that
Trump was the most Libertarian president
I don't get that but uh do either of you
have a strong or interesting reaction to
that statement I mean real quick he look
he he did do tax cuts for sure he tried
to leave a lot of things up to the
states when it came to covid not all of
the things but a decent amount of them
he did scale back some of some of the
war stuff so yes in essence did he do
some of the pieces I'll tell you one of
the reasons that I came around on Trump
over the years was because Rand Paul
really liked him and I and was one of
his main backers in the Senate and I
thought okay Rand Paul who I consider to
be as principled as you can be if you're
going to be in the Senate like he's
defending Trump more than anybody so
that I felt gave me a little room to be
like okay there's there's something
there with this guy yeah uh he did
increase spending massively even before
covet and then after so for me tax cuts
are always interesting and any he
loosened regulations or signaled that
America was more open for business than
it had been but the spending is always
problematic and yeah you know and this
is something just a standard I think
accountant uh based uh you know worry
but also a Libertarian one none of these
guys was talking about entitlement
spending in a way uh that we need to if
if we're if we want to keep America
going over the Long Haul
um Zach do you have uh anything yeah I
mean I I wonder about you know we have
one last clip we wanted to play here
which uh speaks to the idea that none of
these candidates are really speaking to
some of the most important issues that
are facing our country in my opinion and
the the the the social uh the the
culture Wars the the wokeness wars May
in fact just be kind of a distraction
from those more fundamental issues it's
a point that uh your friend uh Peter
Thiel recently made on Barry Weiss's
podcast I want to play that clip real
quick and get your reaction to uh teal
statement as you know another uh fellow
Floridian
the focus on identity Politics on the
woke religion you know is probably a
distraction from stagnation it's a
distraction from economics it's a
distraction from the way in which uh the
younger generation in the U.S uh is
probably going to have a hard time
having as a good standard of living as
their parents and so there's a set of
issues we do not want to talk about you
know I think DeSantis would make it a
terrific president if he's the
Republican nominee I will strongly
support him in 2024 but I I do worry
that uh focusing on on the woke issue as
ground zero is it is not quite enough
so I mean I agree pretty much with Peter
Thiel that while there's aspects of
these culture wars that are important
and worth discussing that they shouldn't
really be Central and we've got bigger
fish to fry there's the lagging economic
growth inflation a lot flows from from
that but there's also the degradation of
our institutions and in some sense like
I was saying before what we really need
is a strict constitutionalist to kind of
restore the balance of powers uh no no
be very clear about where State action
ends and I'm not exactly sure that
DeSantis is that and maybe he's better
than the alternatives on offer at the
moment but uh I just think it's always
worth sticking to our principles and
pointing out how far short just about
every modern politician Falls otherwise
there's really no path towards something
better if we don't kind of keep our eye
on the ball
sure well first off I just think
DeSantis is your guy I think you're
going to begrudgingly I guess or or
maybe a little slower get there but it
just seems obvious to me I mean I think
you will find somebody that has an
absolute respect for the Constitution
and I you know some of the comments that
you read there Nick I mean people are
saying he's going after Free Speech or
something like what can't you say in
Florida you can say whatever you want
okay
um specifically on Teal he happens to be
a good friend of mine so let me not hide
that
um you know I believe that you I like
him a lot and I think he's a brilliant
thinker obviously but I believe that you
can walk and chew gum at the same time
and you can deal with the woke stuff
which by the way Zach when you deal with
the woke stuff you start fixing the
institutions because the institutions
you're worried about they're being
destroyed by woke they're being
destroyed by diversity equity and
inclusion so you can do that at the same
time you then can do all of the things
that have led Florida to be the freest
and most popular uh prosperous state in
the Union and and the proof is only in
the three-fingered pudding it's here
just look what's going on in Florida so
if you were to say to me well he's
focusing on woke so now look what's
happening Florida cities uh are being
overrun by drugs and homeless people
well then we might have an issue if or
or some other version but it's actually
all working here so I I think that that
argument is a little uh thin to me when
you just compare it with the facts on
the ground I just can't as the Zeal with
which you prosecute that war can often
the war on woke can often
cause you to engage and just really
gross State overreach uh in the ways
we've we've already talked about before
I guess we we just disagree on whether
that that constitutes State overreach um
it's the same thing with
um you know cleaning up crime or
cleaning or you know uh controlling the
Border these all these things all sound
good and orderly but there's ways that
if you don't have a strict Fidelity to
the rule of law that they can go
horribly bad and and authoritarian I
mean we didn't even really get a chance
to go much into immigration but some of
how that's played out here has been
alarming whether it's deporting people
to uh Martha's V or you know moving
people from Texas to Martha's Vineyard
or oh I think it's great
I I find it reprehensible to me no no no
no no to use to use people as props like
that and the rhetoric around immigration
I you know this for me is one of the
biggest problems I have with the
Republican party and I and I don't
pretend that the Democratic party is
good on immigration but you know my
grandparents I'm I'm sitting I'm talking
to you from New York City where my
grandparents showed up a hundred years
ago uh they would not be allowed in the
country uh you know now and the anger at
immigrants is just wrong I think the
Republican party is making a huge
mistake by being so zealously
anti-immigrant but well first off I
don't think they're anti-immigrant I
think they are anti-immigrants Donald
Trump Donald Trump Donald Trump wanted
to reduce and he said it constantly I
want to reduce legal immigration as well
as illegal immigration Ron DeSantis is
not talking about legal immigration he's
talking only talks about immigration as
an illegal phenomenon and drugs are
being smuggled across the Mexican border
these that has nothing to do with
immigration policy it has to do with a
failure of immigration policy of letting
people who want to come here and
participate and contribute to American
life so and if we were if we're going to
want economic growth immigration is
going to be a big part of that so I
think there's just
um you know there some of the the focus
the focal points are just wrong at the
moment in from my point of view yeah so
it's unfortunate that we're I think
we're kind of running out of time here
we can do a whole different thing on
immigration because I because because
this is where I'm definitely not fully
in line with the Libertarians I I
believe that we absolutely should have a
fair a strong border once you once you
are here illegally you've already broken
the law we then have to figure out what
to do about that Trump was far more for
amnesty than DeSantis was but Nick I
would be curious I don't know the answer
to this but when you mention your
grandparents 100 years ago I'm guessing
they either Came From Italy or or
Ireland probably Ireland and Italy yes
okay that was pretty solid of me um but
but they were were legal when they came
to LSI they were legal because there was
as long as you weren't Chinese or
Japanese or or South Asian you could get
into the country my Italian grandmother
and this is this is Meaningful I think
she had her first child in America got
home sick went home to Italy and then
couldn't get back in the country because
the laws changed and she was out of the
country for seven years because
overnight the government said you know
what Italians are you know bad they make
bad Americans
um we are going through a spasm of
anti-immigrant sentiment uh which is not
good you know and we are not doing
anything to actually fix legal
immigration there is effectively no way
if you're Mexican and you're not related
to somebody or you're not a millionaire
there's no way to get in the country
legally
um that's going to breed illegal
immigration because the you know the
motivation to come here is not American
immigration laws it's your situation in
your home country It's a larger
conversation Dave I I mean I think to
bring it back to this question about
wokeness and whatnot I think the the
willingness of DeSantis and he's
certainly not alone on this there's
nobody on the Republican side and
effectively nobody on the Democratic
side who's willing to say you know what
I believe in legal immigration
um and here's how I'm going to fix that
as well as secure the Border if the
Border can be secure and if there's a
door in it people will file you know
they'll line up to go through the door
nobody wants to come here illegally pay
a coyote get raped and then have to work
in the black market with the threat of
being sent home like everybody here is
well you know of course people want to
come here legally yeah I think look I
can't speak for incentives on this one
and I think he will this is another one
where I think he will lay out more
policy immigration a little more clearly
as time goes on if but if if we're
basically agreeing that we should have
an we should have a border that is a
defensible border and then a very clean
and clear policy now we may May disagree
slightly on let's say on the numbers of
people or whatever or what what the
reasons are that they can get amnesty or
whatever that's fine but if the I think
the first agreement that you just have
if you believe in nation states if you
believe that there's a difference
between the United States and Mexico and
the United States and Canada and we have
borders then to me you have to have
secure borders and then you have to have
clean and clear laws as to who can come
in when and why and if we do some of
that not easy to do we still have to
deal with the 12 million people who are
here illegally already and what does
that do because should they be you know
in essence granted past yeah breaking
the law in the first place so there's a
lot there that I would say that's a
whole other other show but I but I may
not fall fully in the libertarian no no
that's which I'm not expecting you to
Dave Rubin thank you so much for joining
us to talk about uh Ron DeSantis Florida
your your political hagira from The
Young Turks to uh you know to where you
are now thanks so much and uh we'll look
forward
Florida what the hell are you doing in
New York are you all right you know what
it's uh it's the city I was born in and
I suspect it's the city I'll die in and
I'm gonna die of old age not of random
street crime pretty soon you could enjoy
yourself for another 40 years in Florida
and then we'll send you back to New York
to die I mean all right I'll text you
thanks very much Dave thanks guys
okay so Zach yeah we have a bunch of uh
listener questions
there's a 50 question holy moly Magnum
North uh big spender we all want to Star
like Dave Smith but we have to live in
reality if we make Trump understand what
we want I believe he will do it
okay Keep On Believing but uh I'll I
will say you know uh stop believing the
the libertarian party is obviously
another X Factor for us when we're
deciding how we as Libertarians are
going to vote
um my understanding is is Dave Smith has
declared his his candidacy uh we'll see
what else happens there but
um uh you know it's
it's uh I've become very cynical about
uh National level politics so I'm I
guess more open to Dave uh Dave rubin's
arguments than than I ever have been
that we kind of just at some point just
have to make a choice between really
imperfect uh offerings
um but I think it is incumbent on us to
even if we make that choice you know
hold try to hold people to the highest
standard possible I you know one of the
things I'll say is
um you know
every president going forward or almost
in every election going forward like
politicians need every vote
um and I think part of the function of
Reason uh as well as the libertarian
movement and the libertarian party and
these are all distinct things obviously
is to extract as much uh you know
concessions out of mainstream parties so
it may be you know that Libertarians
make up you know and and we Matt Welch
and I have written about this and you
know
other people have tried to document it
anywhere from about five to fifteen
percent of the of the voting population
can be considered libertarian uh meaning
you know they're generally for limited
government socially liberal fiscally
conservative however you want to slice
that up
um is you know Donald Trump the
Republicans need to pay attention to
Libertarians because Donald Trump in two
elections got 46 percent in change of
the vote he needs 50 percent any
Republican needs 50 to you know more
percent of the vote they can get
Libertarians if they say we are going to
limit the government we're going to
reduce overseas adventurism we're going
to cut spending we're going to cut
regulation we're going to be more open
to Live and Let Live all of these types
of things and you know the Democratic
party also needs us and it's you know
it's up to us to make as much noise to
say not that our votes are for sale but
like if you get in line with a general
libertarian principle about more freedom
uh and allowing a Live and Let Live
world and creating the institutions and
the policies that exemplify that you
know we're going to give you a long look
let's look at one last question here
this is a bit of a long one but I
summarize the beginning of it from Dan
JJ this is another place where
Libertarians lose me what ideals of the
libertarian are represented in the
Progressive Democrat Party the
progressive doesn't stop at equal rights
for transgender people it is a start
point then they always take the next
leap which is inevitable with the
progressive Democrat Party which is to
say they deserve special privileges
so
um
what do you think about that notion that
uh there's ju you know the transgender
discussion is probably a bit too far
afield to go into right now but just the
notion that there is no hope for
Libertarians on the Progressive Side Of
The Ledger that we shouldn't even be
considering anything over there that our
choices are basically to look at the
Republicans or or a long shot
libertarian candidate yeah yeah I I tend
to disagree in the sense of like if
we're talking about Progressive Democrat
Party and I you know I got to tell you I
I always bristle at you know the
Democrat Party which is it it started
out uh as a as a conscious call back to
Joe McCarthy and him railing against
Democrats rather than saying the
Democratic party et cetera
um but uh the fact of the matter is on a
lot of Lifestyle issues that I take
seriously things like gay rights uh
things like immigration uh things like
free speech the Democratic party has as
good or better a drug reform Criminal
Justice Reform has as good or better a
legacy than the Republican Party neither
of these I don't I don't look at one and
say like oh yeah you know one of them is
clearly better than the other uh the
progressive wing of the democratic party
is generally pretty awful but you will
find moments when people like Alexandra
Casio Cortez and Matt Gates you know not
you know who are like very you know uh
very much on different points of of the
political Spectrum come together to
support certain things so there are
elements of the democratic party that I
think you know that when they come to a
policy that I agree with I think they
deserve to be
um you know championed or valorized for
that so yeah and there's individual
Democrats out there who are more who are
you know somewhat libertarian-ish
figures whether you're talking about
Jared Polis in Colorado who just signed
a Statewide psychedelics legalization
into effect and has been good on Tech
policy and even on covid for a blue
State Governor and there's you know
civil Libertarians like Ron Wyden in the
Senate so you know none of these people
are getting promoted to the front of the
party right now it seems like so it's
it's hard to get excited about anyone
you know coming to the the fore on the
uh for the presidential I I'll add to
you know there's uh Bernie Sanders for a
long time I don't know what it's like
now and also the NRA doesn't quite
matter but you know for most of his
career Bernie Sanders had like a hundred
percent writing from the NRA because if
you're from Vermont you're actually in
favor of most federal gun control or
repeal of a lot of federal gun control
legislation so it gets you know it's
more complicated than it seems and I'm
also uh and I'm not sure this gets to
the to the listeners or the viewers
questions in it uh quite in the way that
they might have intended it but it's you
know the rhetoric of the Republican
party to say we are the party of limited
government and yet they constantly do
deficit spending and you know just in
the 21st century alone no president and
no Administration was more ruinous to
libertarian values I think than George W
bush
he absolutely blew out the budget he
increased real spending overall total
spending by 50 percent he prosecuted he
pushed us into two Wars that were
disastrous
um and absolutely terrible uh he
financed that for as long as he could
through supplemental and emergency
Appropriations bill so it didn't go
through actual budgeting process he uh
you know uh uh created ubiquitous
surveillance programs that Barack Obama
you know continued and expanded in
significant ways so it's not one or the
other but the the Republican party used
to talk going back to Ronald Reagan uh
you would talk a Libertarian rhetoric
but they have never lived up to it and
at a certain point especially if we do
have more of a sociological relationship
to Republicans we've got to hold them
accountable it's just it's way way way
past the time to say to Libertarians
it's like you know just vote for us this
time and we'll get around to some of
your priorities the fact of the matter
is is that the Republican party has you
know taken libertarian votes and
sympathies or empathies for granted and
like that has to stop Donald Trump was
you know and I I took a lot of from
uh Libertarians and from recent staffers
because I did not think that Donald
Trump was this you know the the
Antichrist or anything but he massively
increased spending and in significant
ways he increased the reach of
government into everyday life that is
deeply problematic even if he wasn't
perfect but we are so so far past the
moment where uh you know I or I'm so far
past the moment where uh you know
because somebody mumbles something about
Friedrich hiker and Ludwig von mises uh
you know you oh yeah I know we're we're
in the same Club we're not um and I also
you know one of the most interesting
things in Zach I'll give you the last
word to uh you know talk about what you
want to one of the most interesting
things that Dave talked about just in
passing is this generational issue and I
you know I'm turning 60 in August I am a
late you know uh uh the second to last
year of the baby boom the baby boom is
over uh in in the sense of like it is
declining the Sun is setting on the Baby
Boomers and Gen X I'm sorry to tell gen
X's because they never really had their
moment in the Sun but things you know
the the shift that is coming as
Millennials and gen Z move into actual
positions of power is going to be
rocking you know politics and culture
for the next 10 or 20 years
um and it's going to yield something
really interesting because in the end I
or I would argue that people like Ron
DeSantis and AOC May ultimately have
more in common uh you know than they do
with people who are ideologically on
their side because every generational
shift
um and you know Millennials and gen Z
combined are bigger than the baby boom
and Gen X
um you know that you know Generations
have more in common you know uh with
with members of that cohort than they do
with ideologies that you know are kind
of you know across the generation so I
think
right so he's like the one he's there I
guess maybe is hey I I thought he was
actually uh technically a millennial but
I'm not sure you might be right that
might he might be the best hope for Gen
X to have a president yeah well you know
to to close out I guess it's just the
issue that I think is important to both
of us and a lot of Libertarians that
continues to go unaddressed by anyone in
either major party is government
spending national debt uh the risks that
that poses to the future of the country
and that is something that we've had
Vivek ramaswamy on there uh and he kind
of made the case that we're just going
to grow our way out of it and you made a
great follow-up that dissects the logic
there and shows that actually that
that's not really possible so I'd Point
people to that so that they don't fall
for that kind of trick
um I haven't heard you know much out of
DeSantis on this issue Trump is
attacking DeSantis four years ago
suggesting mild reforms to entitlements
so these issues are still you know some
of these Central issues are still not
being directly addressed by it and we
know for a fact this is where I'm
talking about the generational
solidarity Donald Trump and Joe Biden
and all politicians of their age any
politician over 65 has you know said we
will never touch a penny of social
security or Medicare yeah and if you are
committed to that you are committed to
the financial destruction of America
yeah
if there's any presidential candidates
out there who do want to put that at the
at the front of their platform and they
want to come speak with us our we're
wide open you're you're welcome uh
anytime and I thought that the
conversation with Dave was uh fruitful
and uh you know he he made the the
strongest case that uh that he could and
our viewers can decide for themselves
whether that was persuasive or not so
thank you Dave for joining us and thank
you Nick for hosting the conversation
thank you see you next week see you next
week